pour tenter de désamorcer la crise le
gouvernement décide de reporter son
projet de réforme des universités et
avant de discuter de la décentralisation
lundi prochain les syndicats reçus
l'ensemble du texte
dernier tour de piste pour concorde qui
s'est envolé ce matin pour new york le
supersonique attaques hacker accueillis
par des arcs et aquatiques sur le tarmac
retour de mas paris pour ses adieux
avant le sommet du g8 george bush
renouent le dialogue avec la france pas
de colère mais de la déception dit le
président américain qui veut aller de
l'avant les retrouvailles officielles
entre jacques chirac et d'or de bush se
feront à evian à roland garros une
semaine sans faute pour amélie mauresmo
qui s'est qualifiée cet après midi pour
les huitièmes de finale la française n'a
pas perdu un set depuis le début des
internationaux
voilà monsieur bonsoir après les
collèges et les lycées ce sont les
universités qui risquent d'entrer dans
la spirale de la contestation
aujourd'hui le gouvernement signe
d'apaisement a décidé de repousser à
l'automne le projet de loi sur la
réforme contestée des universités ce
report n'a semble-t-il pas calmé les
esprits à perpignan où il organise ou
l'organisation des examens reste très
incertaine après les barricades érigées
par les étudiants reportage verdi
gaglione française mais sow c'était un
peu ce matin comme un camp retranché
avec rsa fassent des non grévistes et
les grévistes
chaque jour un peu triste et paris
devant l'évolution physique à laquelle
nous avons à faire et oui ce serait une
structure physique effectué le monde et
je constate qu'il ya aussi effectivement
des étudiants qui voudraient passer
leurs examens
viendra le suspendre signifier s'ils ne
vient tous les examens de l'université
de perpignan
double plus de la moitié des 7000
étudiants que compte la fac n'a pu
passer ses examens depuis deux semaines
c'est ce que réclame et les assemblées
générales d'étudiants grévistes un
blocage pour protester contre le projet
d'autonomie des universités
ils manifestent pour les hôtels
décentralisation il mélange tout ce qui
va bien aussi au gouvernement mais on ne
peut pas jouer sur l'otage comme ça on
doit laisser les étudiants rêvant de
contrat laisse entrevoir un problème à
ce niveau là le problème est dans les
méthodes utilisées
malheureusement je dis malheureusement
c'est notre seul moyen de pression sur
le gouvernement s'est bloqué les examens
parce que les manifestations
je suis d'accord c'est important mais ça
demande beaucoup d'organisation et ça
gêne que partiellement argent il n'y
aura pas d'examen vont mercredi
peut-être même plus tard et le projet de
loi de modernisation des universités est
reporté à la rentrée mais le campus cet
après midi n'a pas accueilli la nouvelle
comme une victoire
on peut pas être satisfait d'un report
que dépend de ce qui va en sortir et
puis ici le projet revient une telle
quelle ou en septembre et que le
mouvement repart que ce qui me semble à
ce moment là assez probable je ne vois
pas très bien à quoi ça pressé revient
de de reporter nous de reporter le
projet la prochaine mobilisation ces
mardi et ensuite peut-être des examens
en juin à perpignan
et puis rendez vous en septembre avec
les sessions de rattrapage pour les
étudiants mais aussi pour le
gouvernement le monde de l'éducation en
ébullition dans la tente d'une table
ronde lundi prochain au cours de
laquelle luc ferry et nicolas sarkozy
recevant les syndicats voici la feuille
de route tant attendu qui met noir sur
blanc les propositions du gouvernement
en matière de décentralisation la
décentralisation suscitant de nombreuses
crâne du personnel enseignant qui
demande le retrait du projet
florence griffon in duquel 18 heures cet
après midi le texte promis arrivant par
mois de 104 pages à éplucher le
gouvernement a visiblement plancher
jusqu'à la dernière minute
mais les mots qui fâchent sont toujours
là le titre iv prévoit la
décentralisation de l'éducation
aujourd'hui non problème c'est que son
parent et grâce aux sous titres soit
retiré du projet de loi et qu'à partir
de là en plus rediscuter sans a priori
clan d'autres bases
du coup les assemblées générales de cet
après midi comme ici à paris ont toutes
décidé de poursuivre le mouvement
ce l'avancé luc ferry s'est résolu ce
matin a reporté sa réforme sur les
universités
officiellement il a pris la décision de
poursuivre la concertation sur ce projet
un projet qui lui tenait pourtant
particulièrement à coeur au siège de
l'unef le principal syndicat étudiant
on apprécie la nouvelle avec modération
s'agit d'un premier recul après je crois
que ça sera pas forcément suffisant je
crois en être même persuadé pour
j'allais dire qu'à mes calmer la grogne
en cours prochaine étape lundi les
syndicats rencontreront à nouveau luc
ferry mais cette fois ci nicolas sarkozy
le ministre de l'intérieur et de la
décentralisation sera de la partie le
mouvement enseignant continue de se
mobiliser avant la journée du 3 juin des
actions quotidien qui prennent
différentes formes ici une chaîne
humaine à marseille à mulhouse des
professeurs grévistes qui porteront un
brassard ailleurs sous les fenêtres de
jean pierre raffarin un pique nique au
soleil tour d'horizon il a nargué
christophe dutarte ce n'est pas faute de
slogans ni dans vie que certains
professeurs de ce lycée renoncé à
manifester mardi
pourtant ce jour là des grévistes
assureront leur cours
seulement pour les candidats au
baccalauréat et muni de cet accessoire
et brassards rudimentaire mais qui dit
les connaisseurs sont pas des gens
irresponsables qui cherche à rebondir
embêter le monde simplement mais qui ont
des indications véritable as à faire
passer dans le sud est
les enseignants mis sur une valeur sûre
le piquet de grève
trois collèges bloqué ce matin quelques
parents participent même aux barrages un
soutien dont profiterait bien ce
proviseur d'un lycée de fait dans une
lettre adressée aux parents d'élèves
il leur demande tout simplement de
surveiller les épreuves du bac à la
place des grévistes
il me semblait important de prévoir un
dispositif
je dirais intermédiaire qui pourrait
permettre aux enseignants de continuer à
leur mouvement sans pour cela mettre en
cause le déroulement des épreuves du
baccalauréat
l'initiative a suscité l'agacement des
professeurs aucun parent volontaire ne
s'est encore signalé dans le poitou il y
avait presque autant de gendarmes que de
manifestants pour ce pique nique anti
décentralisation les grévistes avaient
planté leurs parasols en face de la
maison de jean-pierre raffarin
ce vendredi 30 mai restera marqué dans
l'histoire de l'aviation commerciale par
le dernier vol paris new york du
concorde d'air france le vol af 007 a
décollé à l'heure de roissy charles de
gaulle sous lé regard embrumé de
plusieurs milliers de fans d'un voyage
historique qui restera marquée longtemps
dans les mémoires des passagers le
supersonique a été accueilli aux états
unis par deux arcs de une haie d'honneur
des pompiers new yorkais abord joël
bruandet sur place notre correspondant
pascal golomer il est un peu plus de 8
heures du matin à new york
le vol air france 0 0 2 se pose pour la
dernière fois sur le sol américain
un vol tout ce qu'il ya de plus
ordinaire avait prévenu la compagnie
aérienne mais quatre heures plus tôt à
paris tout le monde passagers et membres
d'équipage avaient pourtant bien le
sentiment d'embarquer pour un petit
moment d'histoire
l'avion n'affiche pas complet loin de là
beaucoup d'annulations au dernier moment
mais les plus fidèles sont là comme un
dernier hommage à l'esprit de famille
concorde
la chef de cabine et caroline sire est
avec alexis
joël est un cadre la ville
et notamment dans son propos
il a son origine à l'arrière
une petite famille en effet un club de
privilégiés fier de traverser
l'atlantique en 3h30 et à dix sept mille
mètres d'altitude
mc 2 600 mètres par seconde la vitesse
continue de faire rêver
à peine le temps de déguster caviar foie
gras et champagne de discuter entre
couturier cuisinier superstar ministre
ou de savourer l'instant tout simplement
se donner la mort historique projet 50
ans cette année
et je me dis que
dans ma vie je n'ai jamais plus jeunes
aussi haut et aussi vite à l'arrivée à
new york
aucune cérémonie officielle tout juste
un salut amical des pompiers de
l'aéroport
mission accomplie avec dix minutes
d'avancé en cordes passera la nuit à new
york avant de s'envoler pour son ultime
traversée de l'atlantique sous les
couleurs d'air france
un vol qui sonnera pour tous les
amoureux de l'aéronautique comme la fin
d'une époque
mais ceci nous amène à l'extraordinaire
épopée du supersonique qui s'est envolé
pour la première fois en 1969 la même
année où l'homme a mis le pied sur la
lune ou quelques années plus tard
plusieurs liaisons commerciales été mise
en place pour cet appareil qui vole deux
fois plus vite que le son évocation alix
bouilhaguet ce jour-là pour la première
fois concorde va voler 2 mars 1969 sur
le tarmac de l'aéroport de blagnac le
bel oiseau blanc serez l'once à son bord
un équipage français il va grimper
et gagner lafitte ud2
3500 à 4000 m ce vol d'essai ne durera
que 29 minutes
c'est le début d'une aventure
technologique franco-britannique de plus
de 30 en ouverture du parachute droit
nez pointu elle en forme de delta le
concorde vaut la mc2 c'est à dire deux
fois plus vite que la vitesse du son en
janvier 76
les premiers vols commerciaux commencent
dakar rio dé janeiro seul new york fait
de la résistance
trop bruyant trop polluants estime
l'administration américaine il faudra
attendre 1977 pour que le supersonique
puisse enfin se poser outre atlantique
3h45 seulement pour un aller simple
je suis ravi de voler dans un
supersonique et d'avoir ainsi
l'impression d'arriver avant même d'être
parti comme le chanteur sting les stars
les hommes politiques les grands patrons
tous veulent leur billet d'embarquement
j'aurais que jamais la carrière que j'ai
fait aux états unis j'aurais jamais
vendu autant de gino américains et tous
les procédés que j'ai plus bande
et puisque j'ai pu développer j'ai pas
pu prendre le concorde
mais les crises pétrolières vont
rapidement renchérir le coût
d'exploitation de l'appareil
l'objectif de concorde était d'aller
très vite d'un ordre de la planète
c'est un appareil qui consomment
énormément de kérosène donc il ne rentre
plus dans les standards d'exploitation
le 25 juillet 2000 le concorde s'écrase
au décollage de roissy charles de gaulle
bilon 113 morts le supersonique ne s'en
remettra jamais vraiment quelques années
avant la date prévue
le concorde quitte la piste sans
successeur il entreprend son dernier
voyage vers différents musées à travers
le monde avant le sommet du g8 à evian
premières retrouvailles depuis la fin de
la guerre en irak
quelle occasion des cérémonies du
tricentenaire de saint pétersbourg une
quarantaine de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement dont le président français
sont arrivés dans l'ancienne capitale
impériale visites culturelles sous haute
sécurité
en prélude aux discussions diplomatiques
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux vers
une ex ante lives des rancoeurs vue
d'avion saint pétersbourg s'est offert
un beau lifting pour ses 300 ans l'a dit
mi-août in en invitant aux festivités
plus de 40 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement a fait de sa ville natale
pour quelques heures le centre du monde
mais dans les rues désertées par les
habitants la police est partout en civil
en uniforme
le terrorisme ne se laisse pas oublié et
même sur la guerre en tchétchénie n'est
pas au menu des discussions
elle est dans tous les esprits c'est à
la cathédrale sainte isaac que les
principaux dirigeants de la planète se
sont retrouvés pour la première fois
depuis la fin de la guerre en irak
un recueillement apparent sinon une
sincère communion d'esprit l'admirent
poutine et les principaux dirigeants
européens qui était contre la guerre
souhaite en effet renouer au plus vite
et au mieux avec les états unis
jacques chirac sans renier les principes
défendus est acculé au pragmatisme
il voudrait bien tourner la page alors
quand à l'académie polaire on lui offre
la queue de cheval sibérien symbole de
force
le président de la république ne boude
pas son plaisir je souhaite bien entendu
que il permet d'éloigner n'ont pas de
moi mais en tous les cas du g8 à
l'occasion de sa réunion d'éloigner de
saint pétersbourg à l'occasion du
tricentenaire tous les mauvais esprits
on apprécie plus à l'elysée que le
président américain ait décidé de
limiter à 24 heures son séjour à evian
et si george bush a bien dit vive la
france
jacques chirac lui se veut plutôt sobre
je suis très heureux de l'occasion que
j'aurais
de rencontrer président bush et nous
aurons évoqué un des problèmes de la
façon la plus positive
george bush arrivant à demain soir à
saint pétersbourg mais il ne devrait pas
croiser jacques chirac il faudra
attendre
evian les relations franco américaines
sont encore à l'image du temps très
fraîche la ligne tout de même semble à
peu près rétabli entre paris et
washington entre jacques et georges le
président américain qui n'aura donc pas
attendu le début du sommet pour préciser
son état d'esprit à l'égard de la france
s'il y a de la réconciliation dans l'air
en tout cas dans les mots gilles rabin
première étape pour giorgio bouche
cracovie en pologne pays symbole de ce
que les américains appellent la nouvelle
europe
par opposition bien sûr à la vieille
europe c'est qu' avec la france refusait
la guerre en irak à cracovie où les anti
guerre manifester aujourd'hui
le président américain prononcera demain
samedi le grand discours de ce marathon
diplomatique sur les relations futures
entre l'europe et les états unis samedi
la pologne dimanche la russie et saint
pétersbourg pour un tête à tête avec
vladimir poutine et lundi evian le
zénith et la première rencontre entre
george bush et jacques chirac
depuis la brouille autour de la guerre
en irak et les menaces récurrentes de
sanction contre la france n'ont pas de
sanctions je ne suis pas furieux juste
déçu les américains sont déçus mais
maintenant il est temps d'aller de
l'avant
qu'on n'ait pas pu être d'accord avec
notre politique en irak et maintenant il
faut aller de l'avant mardi au lieu de
rester à evian pour la deuxième journée
du g8
george bush rejoindre à charmer cheikh
en egypte pour un sommet avec les chefs
d'état arabes puis mercredi aqaba en
jordanie où il rencontrera séparément
les premiers ministres israéliens et
palestiniens enfin jeudi il sera à doha
au qatar pour visiter les troupes
américaines à charm el cheikh et à aqaba
le président américain tentera de donner
un élan décisif à la fameuse feuille de
route qui voudraient conduire à la
création d'un état palestinien
nous retrouvons en direct de washington
etienne leenhardt alors sans faire
d'angélisme comment doit-on interpréter
les propos bienveillants de george bush
à l'égard de la france où bienveillant
le président américain s'est même fendu
béatrice d'un vive la france qui a dû
faire tomber à la renverse la plupart
des diplomates européens qui sont en
poste ici aux etats-unis on est
clairement dans le registre de la
communication il y a une volonté de part
et d'autre et bien de d'apaiser de
calmer le jeu pour que les vraies
questions du sommet des questions aussi
importantes que la lutte contre le
terrorisme
la bataille contre le sida ne soit pas
occultée par des considérations beaucoup
plus anecdotique se sont ils sourient se
sont ils parlent et se sont-ils serrer
la main le problème c'est que les
désaccords fondamentaux restent
extrêmement profond lorsque le président
chirac redit en début de semaine
publiquement que cette guerre en irak
était illégitime et bien en coulisses
ici à washington on s'étrangle lorsque
le numéro deux du pentagone redit lui
aussi publiquement dit pardon
publiquement et bien que la question des
armes de destruction massive n'était
finalement pas la vraie raison de
l'intervention américaine en irak et
bien en coulisses
en france on s'offusque sur la place de
l'onu sur le droit international toutes
ces questions là ne vont pas rétablir
une franche camaraderie entre la france
et les états unis dans les mois qui
viennent même si le temps d'un sommet on
esquisse des sourires de circonstance
merci etienne leenhardt josé maria aznar
le chef du gouvernement espagnol vient
lui d'annuler son déplacement à saint
petersbourg il ne participera pas au
sommet de l'union européenne avec la
russie en raison de l'attentât qui a tué
deux policiers et un troisième
grièvement blessé un avare au nord de
l'espagne probablement une bombe placée
contre la voiture de police qui est à
l'origine de ce nouvel acte terroriste
attribué à le terrain les militants anti
mondialisation sont entrés en action à
genève ou du moins certains militants
casseurs qui s'en sont pris aux vitrines
de grandes agences internationales les
forces de police les ont repoussés à
coup de grenades lacrymogènes
pas de blessés ni d'arrestations dans le
cortège des jeunes près de 2000 qui ont
défilé dans les rues désertées de la
ville
le g8 qui attire dans son sillage un
grand nombre de journalistes de
délégations étrangères et surtout des
policiers qui sont logés avoriaz en
cette période de basse saison la station
à irene est dit comme le montre ce
reportage de mathias hillion josé
boulesteix police partout touristes
nulle part
avoriaz 100 habitants en basse saison et
2007 150 crs pendant ce g8
les forces de l'ordre ont entièrement
réservé la station 1500 chambres
occupées par une population masculine en
bleu marine
opération séduction réussie pour ses
clients aux cheveux courts
ils sont gentils véhicule est
habituellement avoriaz est interdite aux
voitures mais à événement exceptionnel
concession exceptionnel les véhicules de
police ont pu envahir la station il faut
dire que cette vague le rapporte
beaucoup d'argent aux commerçants
avoriaz est généralement fermée à cette
époque sur nos mille cinq cent cinquante
appartements 1300 sont occupés par des
crs ou sécurité publique donc on peut
dire que 95 % de nos parcs est occupée
actuellement grâce à l'événement g8
merci les crs merci les crs évidemment
merci
difficile de connaître le coût global de
ces réquisitions
on sait en tout cas que les hôteliers
d'avoriaz ont fait une grosse ristourne
aux policiers et militaires qui
assureront la sécurité de ce sommet
place aux contres se met avec l'exemple
de ces jeunes qui en fait le déplacement
pour manifester leur volonté leur espoir
en un monde nouveau
ambiance plutôt festive reportage à
annemasse nathalie moisan emmanuel bec
2003 toute la planète est occupée tout
non un petit village résiste encore
celui des altermondialistes alerte
générale en allemand en espagnol
un appel à la mobilisation est lancé les
jeunes qui campent aux portes damas se
ruant manifestation spontanée pour
couper une route
une rumeur une de plus après
vérification pas de convois sur la route
l'opposition ou g8 restera symbolique
pour l'instant sa part assez bizarre que
le cortège passe justement sous le nez
du camp je crois qu'il faut pas qu'on
soit naïf et qu'effectivement ils n'ont
pas passé à l'intérieur du village pour
emmener tous à evian l'autogestion n'est
certes pas une pratique facile pourtant
c'est un principe ici on rêve de changer
le monde
nous on est juste l'étincelle je pense
n'est pas celle qui chaque jour commence
à se transformer un petit à petit en un
grand brasier que comme quoi les gens
sont pas d'accord à chaque manifestation
à chaque contre sommet du g8 ou de l'om
sait qu il ya de plus en plus de monde
au parc pour tous ces jeunes le village
est un espace de rencontre et d'éveil
politiques avant la grande manifestation
de dimanche de part et d'autre de la
frontière suisse
et puis il ya ceux qui sont pour la
mondialisation et à l'exemple de cet
agriculteur qui y trouvent de très
nombreux avantages reportage près
d'evian champel chapelle l'anip tri
boire la garde républicaine a investi
les lieux
dans cette ferme près d'evian
l'agriculteur est plutôt flatté
d'accueillir le plus noble éléments du
dispositif sécuritaire assez sympathique
plus facile à vivre au coeur
une escouade de crs michel grivel et
surtout fier de son fromage l'abondance
90 kg par jour produit dans le plus
grand respect des traditions
qui date de près 180 il faut le vendre
qu'il faut le vendre à qui ose les
autres les autres ils sont partout ils
sont de l'autre côté du lac était déjà
l'étranger tout près de la suisse
la haute-savoie bénéficie toute l'année
d'un tourisme haut de gamme
pour lui la mondialisation ça a du bon
et le g8
c'est un effort louable pour tenté de la
maîtriser j'ajoute en plus il n'ya pas
régulièrement des rencontres on va
abandonner au pays dominants régulier au
sol pays dominants hélicoptère de
surveillance et motards de gendarmerie
ne perturbe pas les quelques 60 vaches
de l'exploitation
le paysan lui c'est qu'une fois passée
la gêne occasionnelle le g8 aura donné à
la région un coup de projecteur sur son
économie et ses produits en particulier
alors il en profite pour exprimer sa
vision du monde
je le dis aux chutes et un jeudi à
dimanche je crois qu'il faut s'appuyer
sur ses racines pour aller vers les
autres
il faut pas oublier ses racines un
message qu'il espère faire entendre aux
chefs d'état réunis dimanche à un
kilomètre et demi de là pour ce long
week-end de l'ascension les gendarmes
ont mis en place un dispositif invisible
pour les conducteurs
les gendarmes sont en civil leur voiture
est banalisée et un séreux milieu de la
circulation ils contrôlent les verbalise
difficile d'y échapper
exemple de cette opération pilote en
vendée unique pour l'instant france
reportage françois privat capitaine
jeans et paulo voici la nouvelle tenue
du gendarme de l'escadron de sécurité
routière devant des partants pour une
opération de contrôle voiture banalisée
jusqu'à la plaque d'immatriculation
premiers kilomètres et déjà une
infraction difficile à verbaliser en
temps normal une ford fiesta grise
pour les distances de sécurité et
quelques secondes plus tard la voiture
est intercepté par deux motards m'étais
aperçu monsieur vous est il que vous
aviez dépasser alors leaf est ravi que
bella lisez donc je préfère qu'on fait
du tout et cette opération discrétion
démontre rapidement son efficacité lors
de la traversée d'un village vers le
monsieur avec la peugeot ou grises et
passe à 5 ans jusqu'au croisement
derrière vous là ce que nous aimerions
c'est aussi créer un climat d'insécurité
pour les délinquants routiers potentiel
en se disant que le vécu qui est devant
nous c'est peut-être des gendarmes ou de
la moto quettehou de carrefour
ces vedettes un drame donc ça peut
peut-être faire réfléchir certains font
du totalement dans la circulation
le dispositif permet également des
contrôles de vitesse d'un nouveau genre
donc un véhicule qui circule à vive
allure sur les comptes temps des
scooters
alors je suis 130
lorsque bonjour vous êtes producteur de
la vitesse d'un hôtel de torpiller
répandit continuellement à 140
c'est pas possible
dans quelques mois au terme de cette
opération pilote il sera décidé ou non
d'étendre ce dispositif à tous les
escadrons de gendarmerie de sécurité
routière en france pour ceux qui ont la
chance de faire le pont quatre jours de
soleil est annoncé avec une météo au
beau fixe
la française show is dore au soleil
comme ici à l'île de ré l'affluence des
beaux jours en bretagne et en
particulier à belle île où les touristes
ont découvert avec déception des
boulettes de fioul sur les plages se
fait rude y est voici ce qu'ils ont
trouvé ce matin
du soleil du sable fin et des boulettes
de fioul
pas de quoi se réjouir pour ces
vacanciers de belle île depuis deux
jours des arrivages réguliers de pétrole
sous les plages de la région
c'est l'horreur vraiment cette soudure
cc c'est vraiment ça nous a fait mal au
coeur ce conseiller on est allé chercher
des sacs tout bêtement on s'est pris
nous sacrifions namys complète dans à
belle île entre 7 et 15 tonnes de
pétrole sont ramassés tous les jours
sans savoir s'il provient du naufrage du
prestige pour l'instant les plages ne
sont pas interdites au public certains
élus dénoncent cette situation c'est
l'enjeu économique qui dicte tout
on oublie en fait le désastre écologique
que peut-être aussi ce goudron qui font
et qui se répand aussi sur les jeux tout
l'écosystème en attendant les renforts
prévus la semaine prochaine
les touristes eux pourraient bien passer
plus de temps à ramasser des boulettes
cas bronzer sur la serviette
revenons-en aux chiffres du chômage qui
se sensibiliser à peu près avec une
infime progression de 0 1% en avril
après cinq mois de hausse
au total la france compte deux millions
trois cent soixante dix mille 300
demandeurs d'emploi la question des
retraites reste un sujet brûlant et la
réforme engagée par le gouvernement a
été globalement critiqué par
l'opposition une voix pourtant
dissonante celle de l'ancien premier
ministre michel rocard qui dénonce
l'attitude du ps considérant comme
extrêmement dangereux sa demande de
retrait du plan fillon
nous écoutons messieurs regard il faut
c'est une folle c'est la surenchère
logiciel une foudre la lady à la
violence oui qu'est ce qu'il a faire de
l'eso pendant longtemps le ps s'est fait
plaisir sur un moment qui est le mois de
mai 19 en 2003 mais on va vieillir
on peut très bien gagner les élections
prochaines parce que tout sera très
content le jura pas six mais il faudra
perdre convient on frappe au près pareil
et à ce moment là vers la ribot qui on a
fait une ovation se vendait à dire où
les ventes y avait décidément la
contestation sociale rattraper les
ministres du gouvernement déplacement à
si nicolas sarkozy est venu une nouvelle
fois encore se défendent le référendum
prévu en juillet prochain a été
accueilli chaleureusement à corte
reportage vincent fourcade à la location
à corte pas de nationalistes pour
rencontrer nicolas sarkozy
ce sont les grévistes de la fonction
publique qui s'occupe aujourd'hui de
l'accueil
je vois je suis septième visite en corse
en moins d'un an et tous le même
objectif promouvoir le oui au projet de
fusion des deux départements de l'île à
corte comme ailleurs je crois que pour
certains d'entre eux c'était une
surprise que je sois là et je pense que
ma place était là parce que corte et en
corse
la corse et la france de la place d'un
ministre de la république est d'être
dans tous les endroits être partout et
au plus vite alors que le oui au
référendum semble perdre du terrain car
pour nombre de corses ce scrutin
pourrait être un moyen détourné de dire
non à d'autres réformes en cours
je pense qu'il ira votre réaction avec
en corse 41 % de fonctionnaires y aura
une influence la journée de nicolas
sarkozy avait pourtant bien débuté mais
je compte sur vous sur toi moi j'ai
besoin de vous de certaines à ajaccio la
campagne pour le oui ce fait au pas de
course
plus qu'un mois pour convaincre les 190
mille électeurs de l'île que ce projet
améliorera leur avenir
le meilleur ouvrier soit il ne peut pas
travailler s'il n'a pas un outil adapté
à sa mission l'outil adapté à notre
mission c'est une organisation
territoriale simplifiée mais plus que
jamais l'issue du référendum reste
incertaine
il faudra attendre le 6 juillet pour
savoir quel futur
les corses choisiront pour l'heure il
j'en viens à cette affaire de viol d'une
adolescente par des camarades de classe
les quatre mineurs ont été interpellés
laëtitia le gendre edouard paiera une
simple feuille d'information distribuée
à chaque les lèvres le collège george
sand de paris est au coeur de la
tourmente depuis plusieurs mois une
adolescente de 12 ans et demi qui
fréquentaient cet établissement a été
violée par quatre adolescents à peine
plus âgé qu'elle
les garçons dont l'a été son petit ami
viennent d'être mises en examen ce sont
les résultats scolaires en baisse qui
ont alerté un professeur ici tout le
monde est bouleversé
certains parents connaissent l un des
agresseurs ils ne comprennent toujours
pas c'est un enfant qui était à la
maison encore vendredi
qui très politique et très gentille
enfin moi ça fait des années que je le
connais jamais eu de souci avec lui le
couvert email
et alors vous en avez parlé de votre
enfant j'en ai parlé un petit peu mais
il veut plus revenir à l'école les
quatre adolescents ne viennent pas d'un
milieu particulièrement défavorisées il
n'était connu ni de la police ni des
services éducatifs et pourtant celeron
pu traîner avec dès la semaine prochaine
médecins et psychologues vont venir au
collège écouter parler avec les autres
élèves leur expliquer aussi qu'une
adolescente violée par quatre garçons ne
peut pas être consentante
nous avons entendu ces propos qui sont
insupportables imaginez que c'est jeune
fille était consentante était volontaire
c'est absolument insultant j'allais dire
pour le genre humain en général donc
notre volonté se faire comprendre à ses
enfants qu'il est lui à atteindre ou
plus profond j'allais dire à l'existence
et aux droits de la personne humaine
depuis les gars ont été éloignés du
collège et placé en foyer
les versions de la sphère divergent dans
les prochaines semaines il pourrait y
avoir une confrontation entre la victime
et ses agresseurs
en algérie les secousses sont
quotidiennes depuis le tremblement de
terre qui a fait je vous le rappelle
plus de 2200 morts et dix mille blessés
dans la capitale on vit dans la crainte
d'une nouvelle réplique les rumeurs vont
bon train même les plus folles on parle
même d'un raz-de-marée loïc de la
mornais frédéric bonnet
normal
détruite la mosquée de reghaïa n'a pu
accueillir la grande prière du vendredi
alors on prie en rang sur les trottoirs
et l'imam prêche dans un immeuble en
chantier
il explique que le tremblement de terre
est un test de dieu pour éprouver la foi
des croyants et au sujet des victimes et
la destinée de chacun est inscrite dès
la naissance
là des gens qui disent qu'ils sont une
catastrophe naturelle non c'est la
volonté de dieu on ne sait pas quand et
comment mais petite entorse au fatalisme
religieux l'imam promet tout de même les
portes de l'enfer aux promoteurs véreux
qui n'ont pas respecté les normes de
construction pour ses habitants d'alger
le sort divin s'acharne anciens
sinistrés des meurtrières aux
inondations de bab el oued
puis relogés dans ce quartier ils sont à
nouveau contraint aux tentes de fortune
seuls deux experts sont venus les voir
l'un pour leur assurer qu'il n'y avait
aucun risque
l'autre pour leur interdire de remonter
chez eux et puis il ya les rumeurs
d'annoncé on dise on nous a traumatisés
c'est le média arabe donc et qui
viennent d'annoncer ont disons que plus
tard dans d'anciens courant de cette
semaine y rappelait uras est in qui va
taper encore alger avec cette plus fort
avec 7,2 avec 7 degrés aujourd'hui le
bruit court qu'un raz-de-marée va
maintenant submerger la ville mais les
habitants n'ont pas le choix et seules
quelques familles tentent l'exode vers
d'autres régions du pays
l'absence des autorités facilite
largement la circulation des rumeurs ce
soir encore par peur d'une réplique ou
par fantasme d'une autre catastrophe des
milliers d'algérois dormiront dehors
mais ils ne quitteront pas leur ville
pour autant c'est aussi un peu cela le
fatalisme musulmans paris qui devrait
débloquer une aide financière importante
pour aider l'algérie via temps
d'apprendre ce soir on maroc le roi
mohamed 6 a décidé d'entrer en guerre
contre le terrorisme
un message à la nation pour duquel le
roi affirmé que venait la fin de l'ère
du laxisme en israël la rencontre entre
les premiers ministres
ariel sharon et son homologue
palestinien mahmoud abbas est qualifiée
de très positive avant l'arrivée de
george bush la semaine prochaine pour un
sommet tripartite israël annonce des
mesures d'allègement pour les
palestiniens c'est à dire
assouplissement du blocage et libération
d'une centaine de prisonniers
et puis à bagdad l'une des images
symboles de la fin du régime de saddam
hussein et celle vous vous en souvenez
du déboulonnement de la statue de
l'ancien dictateur aujourd'hui les
artistes des étudiants mis tout leur
talent pour créer une nouvelle structure
qui prendra place dans le centre ville
on retiendra ce croissant de lune servol
de l'islam en france
émotion inquiétudes chez les
archéologues français chargés des
fouilles préventives à vendre la
construction de grands chantiers
un projet de loi va réformer leur métier
daniel wolfromm jean moulin de loin ils
ont la lure de terrassier ou de
jardinier bien difficile de deviner
leurs activités en fait ce sont des
archéologues sur leurs lieux de fouilles
de fouilles préventives même car ils
sont chargés en urgence avant
l'exploitation de ce site en carrière
d'arracher à la terre ces vestiges
néolithique vieux de sept mille ans
les vins ce qu'on avait on a commencé à
remonter de la fosse précédentes la
barre de son papa la même chose à
mareuil
bien mais ce matin nous trois
archéologues sont inquiets et non pas
trop la tête à leurs découvertes leurs
institutions est en déficit et leur
ministère leur demande des efforts
restrictions en moyens et en personnel
il ya d'autres vestiges d'autres
vestiges plus récent de l'âge du fer
mais qu' on n'aura malheureusement pas
le temps de fouiller pourquoi à cause du
faible nombre qu'on est con restera
jusqu'à la date butoir question va
devenir tout ça va ça va être rendue à
la carrière donc ça sera détruit
d'autres sites sont menacés pas assez de
temps pour les archéologues trop de
fouilles
selon le ministère mon objectif c'est
justement de les tirer d'affaires c'est
de faire en sorte que l'établissement
qui les emploient l'inrap ne sombre pas
purement et simplement
aujourd'hui cet établissement à un
déficit important 45 millions d'euros
je vais laurent plouay renflouer certes
mais aussi ouvrir les fouilles à la
concurrence entre équipes
c'est cela que la plupart de ces
scientifiques redoutent
l'enjeu est important l'archéologie
préventive c'est la sauvegarde du
patrimoine comme ici sous le terre-plein
de cet hôpital de bobigny la fouille
d'une des plus belles nécropole gauloise
découvertes à ce jour la qualité
sportive est à roland garros tout ce que
touche amélie mauresmo se transforme en
victoire une semaine sans faute pour la
française qui s'est qualifié pour les
huitièmes de finale nathanaël de
rincquesen alain poirier avec sa jupette
et ses entrechats elle fait penser à une
danseuse
n'oubliez pas aux apparences sur le
court amélie mauresmo rechercher le
chaos
fabiola zuluaga la colombienne a bien
tenté de résister aux assauts de son
adversaire
mais cet après midi la numéro un
française et est irrésistible
elle remporte le premier set 6 jeux à 3
dans la deuxième manche mauresmo ne rate
pas grand chose un point par ci laissé à
son adversaire un grand spectacle offert
à ses supporters
finalement amélie mauresmo s'impose 6 3
dans le deuxième set
la voilà déjà en huitièmes de finale
c'était super je crois que de sentir
cette atmosphère de sentir ce public
avait qu'a vraiment envie que je joue
bien que je gagne et donc c'est vrai que
ça donne un petit peu des ailes ça donne
envie de bien jouer
j'ai assuré le vraiment le la victoire
aujourd'hui donc c'est super après midi
va opposer andre agassi le belge xavier
malisse s'attendait à ce que l'américain
soit émoussé par ses 5 s'est disputé
avant-hier
visiblement soucieux d'économiser le
numéro deux mondial s'est montré
expéditif trois petits sets et deux
heures de jeu à 33 ans papa agassi est
en pleine forme
on voit une ferreira en revanche roland
garros se termine sur une civière
le sud africain l'ancien numéro 6
mondial a tenu à rassurer le public
avant d'être évacués opposé à l'allemand
schüttler ferreira s'est blessé aux
adducteurs lors d'une glissade bien mal
contrôlé et puis aux états unis tony
parker est le premier français s'est
qualifié pour la finale du championnat
professionnel de basketball le nba
victoire donc pour le meneur de jeu tony
parker et les spurs de san antonio qui
se sont qualifiés en remportant leur
quatrième victoire le grand-père du
large et les vacances avec cette semaine
du golfe du morbihan rassemblement de
voiliers du vieux gréements au petit
bateau de plaisance une véritable armada
jacques devaux michel hiver
ils sont de toutes les couleurs de
toutes les tailles de tous les types
ancien bateau de travail ou de plaisance
mais tous ou presque ont leur histoire
à l'image de ceux ci nago le bateau de
pêche traditionnelle du golfe au début
des années 80 il avait pratiquement
disparu quand des passionnés ont décidé
d'en reconstruire à l'identique
il a préféré conçu en tranches et
carbonneau de france aujourd'hui et non
c'est bon comme ça reste comme ça
d'accord le bateau est aussi passion de
toute une vie voilà plus de quarante ans
que jean bourgeois navigue sur guy nick
deux ce bateau il l'a construit de ses
mains et mis à l'eau sur la scène c'est
à bateaux de pêche et d'ailleurs il est
construit comme ça en embrouille orcier
vous savez puis cloué mais moi ce que je
voulais c'est un bateau pour faire
naviguer la famille et puis moi alors
j'ai donc modifier les plans touchent
que j'en ai un petit bateau
hubert o'neill le lui ne jure que par le
guépard le dériveur du golf conçu et
construit ici au début des années 60 un
bateau tellement bien adapté au golf que
sa construction a repris on peut faire
des pique-niques avec en famille avec
toutes les générations le régates et
parce que ce tram au nautic et qu'on est
comme je faisais une quarantaine de
bateaux donc ça à tous les avantages de
ce petit bateau de
river léger et plus la convialité
d'amato presque de croisière en deux
petites croisières
samedi plus de 600 bateaux seront de la
parade
une longue procession nautique descendra
le golf toutes voiles dehors
un spectacle à vous donner envie de
monter à bord les obsèques de jean yanne
ce sens déroulée dans l'intimité cet
après-midi uni la en seine-saint-denis
le comédien est décédé d'une crise
cardiaque à l'âge de 69 ans il ya une
semaine pour ce dernier hommage des
anonymes et puis les comédiens comme
michel serrault mireille darc ou encore
gérard jugnot théâtre avec l'entrée au
répertoire de la comédie française d'un
grand dramaturge russe alexander trotsky
précurseur de tchekhov à travers l'un de
ses chefs-d'oeuvre la forêt reportage se
fige jean moulin denis podalydès michel
villermaux deux acteurs du français qui
se transforme en comédien sans le sou de
la russie profonde pour servir l'un des
plus grands auteurs de ce pays
alexandre ostrowski l'équivalent de
molière pour les russes nous sommes très
fiers
l'univers de strahovski c'est cette
russie où les dames vieillissante mettre
le grappin sur de jeunes sont messieurs
si je vous présente un jeu aristocrate
alexis seule guest boulard une société
médiocre sans horizon des styles est
très intéressante vais vous raconter
tout de suite aller vous promener dans
le corps que l'on a mis une société ou
un acteur ambulant est un paria
même s'il est le neveu de la
propriétaire battante
c'est une dame respectable c'est ben non
je veux pas mieux qu'elle sache que je
suis adapté elle prouve à cyano plus
attention aux catalans monsieur gainey
demiani capitaine en retraite au malheur
du corps et enfin comme ça tu chantes en
un mot je suis à monsieur doit à
laquelle on a tous les acteurs de
l'expérience de lyon l'a été même de ses
comédiens 10 de province à qui hier un
peu de cachet en cash et les
intermittents
heureusement dans ce monde corrompu il y
a les acteurs qui ont du coeur pour
ostrosky auteurs majeurs du 19e siècle
seul théâtre peut sauver le monde et
vous toute votre vie où j'ai regretté
sur le bien-être de la société sur
l'amour du prochain
et qu'avez vous fait ainsi se termine ce
journal dans un instant la météo patrice
drevet 20h55 maigret avec bruno cremer 0
h 15 le dernier journal est venue était
de master dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit ou telle amber
quant à moi j'aurais plaisir de vous
retrouver dès 13 heures demain je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente 500 sur français